[Musique]
depuis le 1er janvier 2016 les deux
agences de développement économique des
départements alsaciens ont fusionné en
une seule agence la dir
l'association de développement et
d'industrialisation de la région alsace
une structure qui regroupe différents
échelons des collectivités locales à
savoir les deux départements haut-rhin
et bas-rhin et les agglomérations de
strasbourg mulhouse colmar saint louis
et haguenau objectif de l' agence qui
compte une trentaine de salariés
soutenir l'économie locale et les
théâtres la dira c'est l'outil de
développement de l'alsace
l'adira est née de la fusion des deux
agences de développement économique du
haut-rhin et du bas-rhin et c'est
vraiment un outil que nous utilisons
pour accompagner les entreprises et les
territoires la dira c'est vraiment un
outil de la deûle à proximité dont les
entreprises ont besoin
la grande force de la dira c'est sa
souplesse et sa réactivité
l'adira est composé d'une équipe de 30
personnes et nos équipes sont
à l'ecoute des entreprises toujours
prête à les conseiller en matière de
développement et même souvent pour être
des médiateurs avec les administrations
avec lesquelles ce pas toujours facile
avec les collectivités bien entendu est
également parfois avec les avec les
banques un exemple d'entreprise suivi
par l'adira crown ceram installé à
wittelsheim près de mulhouse ce
laboratoire de prothèses dentaires
travail avec la france entière pour
soutenir son projet de développement
l'agencé économique l'a aidé à recruter
du personnel qualifié à faciliter ses
contacts avec la chambre des métiers
pour les questions de formation mais
aussi avec les collectivités pour que le
labo puisse implantée sur un site plus
grand
l'adira est aux côtés des entreprises
pour leur faciliter la démarche de sorte
que les chefs d'entreprise puisse rester
au maximum dans ce qui est leur coeur de
métier
lorsque j'étais devenu président du car
j'ai souhaité rencontrer les chefs
d'entreprise et j'en ai rencontré une
centaine leurs témoignages étaient
éloquents il nous disait à quel point ça
pouvait difficile pour eux
lorsqu'il s'agissait dans une démarche
de développement de trouver les bons
interlocuteurs et certains chefs
d'entreprise
excédé nous disait mais écoutez il faut
vraiment nous aider parce que nous notre
métier c'est pas ça notre métier c'est
de produire ce qui est de notre domaine
c'est pas de courir après les
administrations ou de voir quel est le
bon fonctionnaire qui apportera la bonne
signature facilité
les démarches des entreprises un rôle
indispensable dans un contexte
économique difficile
bien sûr de nombreux dispositifs
existent pour soutenir les entrepreneurs
encore faut-il que ces derniers en
connaissent l'existence ou disposent du
temps et des moyens pour les mobiliser
la dir joue ce rôle de médiateur et de
personnes ressources
une façon de soutenir la croissance des
entreprises sans pour autant engager de
fonds propres des fois une bonne écoute
et des conseils sont plus payant que des
subventions en 2016
l'adira a suivi 441 projet
d'installation d'entreprises ou de
développement d'entreprise industrielle
ou dans le tertiaire supérieur et parmi
ces 4 141 projets qui ont été suivis 145
ont été décidées ou réaliser ça concerne
en matière d'emplois créés ou maintenus
et je parle seulement des emplois
directs 1883 emploi en 2016 et le
montant des investissements qui ont été
concernés par ces projets c'est 549
millions d'euros
quand on a ces chiffres on voit quel est
l'enjeu qui lie à d'avoir un outil comme
la dira auprès des chefs d'entreprise
[Musique]